the reason it's so easy for me is I know
everybody has their own problems nobody
gives a [ __ ] about me once you
understand that nobody gives a [ __ ] [ __ ]
gets real interesting
you got your perspective it is true I
have absolutely no idea what I'm about
to do I'm really excited to be here
I had an last year when I was here
somebody gave me an All Blacks Jersey
with my name on it and I was super
pumped and I promised to wear it and is
it you dude so I was super pumped I
packed it right number-5 Vaynerchuk I
was super fired up so like I basically
like squeeze every minute so I'm in the
hotel room and it's like I have to
shower and get ready in like four
minutes and meet everybody downstairs
and I rush and I put it on and it's a
small [ __ ] I was I was so fired up to
wear it but I didn't get fit enough in
that year but I appreciate it now I'm
gonna have to frame it anyway I'm super
thrilled to be here thank you for coming
there's a whole lot of different things
on my mind I am really really excited
for Q&A so I'm looking forward to that
so please line up for that because I
think the details matter I think a lot
of the macro points of view that I share
if you consume my content you're gonna
hear them you're gonna understand them
you know the ironic thing is I think
there's two things I do extremely well
and they're very very very different one
I'm extremely good historically and I
hope to continue to be at understanding
where the current attention graft of
human beings are what platforms what
technologies are capturing our attention
and how do I become a storyteller on
those platforms and build business you
know my dad's liquor store was a
business that was not making a whole lot
of profit off of it three and a half
million dollar base and I grew it to a
60 million dollar business
in a heartbeat because every penny I was
spending on Google AdWords email
marketing and having a website in 1996
to 2001 was worth dollars every nickel
was worth dollars and that's how it got
built quickly my career is a very
similar story in 2006 and 2007 I was
producing enormous amounts of content
for YouTube and Twitter that ended up
working out and and that has basically
been my whole career I come here today
and can tell you regardless of what you
do for a living no matter what you are
selling or what kind of professional you
are no matter if you're b2b or b2c I
know standing here right now that the
two biggest arbitrage is as platforms in
this market are tik-tok and LinkedIn
right I know that if you go home and
spend 30 hours and really research the
content that's working on both
tick-tocks very young but so is
Instagram and Facebook LinkedIn is no
longer just business and if you sell
workout equipment and just put out
content there it will work so what I've
done really well my whole career is play
in two very opposite directions one the
State of the Union of the consumer which
basically is day trading I have to look
at that stuff every day every day I'm
paying attention and I have to spend a
lot of times on things that don't work
out I spent enormous amounts of time on
apps like social km and apps like peach
and apps like vero and viddler and many
other things that many people here don't
even know because that's part of what I
have to do to stay on top of things you
hear about the ones that work out nobody
cries for me about the 50 hundred hours
I spent in a couple months on a platform
that you know a month later means
nothing and all that time was wasted
that's what I do over here the other
thing I do which is all the way over
here is I basically have five seven 1322
core principles that have been always
true in business in perpetuity right
which is I am desperate desperate with
this audience to be the person that
provides the most value for free
desperate everyday how do I put in all
these hours of work and then how do I
put it out on LinkedIn YouTube podcast
Facebook Twitter for free it is not a
funnel to get you to pay for something
it is [ __ ] free period end of story
and so I do that and that is giving more
than you ask in return if you're running
a marathon and trying to build a
meaningful business that will always
work out patience I believe in it
I believe that we live in a fast society
now where people can see millions of
different things and see different
impressions of what people are doing and
get very quick into FOMO or why haven't
I and the reality is I believe in
patience almost more than anything and
it comes so not natural everybody's
looking for the passive for the angle
for the quick fix how do I get there
faster how do I get there faster how do
I get there easier literally the only
thing that's interesting to me is slow
and hard literally the only thing that's
interesting to me in business is slow
and [ __ ] difficult and that is
basically completely polar opposite to
the 99% of advice that is being put out
there today so for me those are the two
frameworks for me how my fastest [ __ ]
and how do I go super hard and how do I
while I'm standing there looking into
things to be prepared for what I do for
a living and then how do I go at the
highest level in my mind in my mind slow
in my mind and my strategy slow
tried-and-true the [ __ ] your great-great
grandparents believed in is the [ __ ]
that I believe in mentally and then in
action I go fast and hard
I sleep seven eight six and a half hours
a day everybody thinks it's 2:00 or 3:00
it's because I go so hard the other 15
16 I believe that that is the reverse of
most people I think mentally everybody
wants it fast and easy and I think in
their actions they're slow they like
take lunch and [ __ ]
and it's it that is how I see the world
that is what I observed from others the
question for me over the last half
decade is why am i able to go fast why
am i comfortable to give the advice that
I tell you so much of the fluffy ship
that I find myself in now which is
parenting advice mental advice happiness
empathy gratitude it all came from my
frustration of 20 14 15 16 when I'm
giving you the keys do you understand in
the first two minutes of this talk I
delivered on what many of you actually
want for me which is I've been so
consistently right and there is so much
value in being first right it's always a
game of best you can still start a
youtube channel and a podcast tomorrow
and completely dominate even everybody's
doing it because you're just better at
your genre but being first helps if
you're right about first it does help
and that is a far majority of what
people want for me when I read my DMS my
emails my text messages
and I gave it to you already it's done
for 80% of the people the thing you're
looking for for me has been delivered
it's called tick tock and Linkedin you
can go [ __ ] home and eat the
interesting thing though for that 80%
that we're looking for it is 98% of them
won't do anything about it
that is what's interesting to me how
many people here by show of hands are in
the b2b business raise your hand raise
it high please forever keep it up high
please rely and everybody don't half-ass
it I want to see it thank you for some
of the late hands just throw it up I'm
just real curious for everybody who's
got their hand up thinking you could put
it down for everybody who just put up
their hand if you are not producing 25
pieces of content a day for LinkedIn you
are [ __ ] up 25 a day most people
haven't posted 25 pieces of content that
just raised their hands in their life on
LinkedIn it's happening everything that
you heard other people took advantage of
on Facebook and Instagram from 2011 to
2006
Dean is happening right now in the b2b
space on LinkedIn to me the question is
if you're here and you know who I am and
you've been hearing it from me for the
last eight months
why aren't you posting that is what I'm
trying to figure out is it that you
don't know what the [ __ ] you're actually
selling and so you're scared to expose
yourself happens I believe in that [ __ ]
is it that when you get one negative
comment you fold like a cheap [ __ ]
chair that's the majority and that
laughs and that majority is what's led
me to this mindset thing that I spend a
lot of time on which is like oh [ __ ] I
need to be very grateful and feel a
little guilty that the circumstances of
so much adversity as a child of being an
immigrant not speaking the language
getting picked on for that being
terrible at school not being great at
sports that because my entire childhood
was adversity that I fell in love with
losing I loved no I loved your judgement
I love you telling me I'm not or I can't
I'm used to it I can't believe that I
stand here today during this time and
have now understood that all the stuff
that sucked as a child all that
adversity is completely the foundation
of my success that we live in a
generation now of so much prosperity for
so long and we have over coddled two
generations of adults that most people
just can't deal with adversity which is
the biggest reason people struggle with
putting out content on the internet
because they can't deal with the
judgment so many people here know
exactly what to do to have a much
happier life and don't do it because one
account that's anonymous makes fun of
them and they can't move forward that is
interesting as [ __ ] and so I'm spending
more time trying to figure out how to
unlock that I talk more and more about
you know if I can get one person here to
leave today to go home and
we have a conversation with their mom
their dad or their spouse and actually
tell them what they're thinking and
actually tell that person in their face
why they're so upset with them because
they continue to spew negativity and no
to them which is what's actually
stopping them from living their life if
I can get one person to do that here
that would be a good use of my time in
New Zealand on this trip right so to me
that's what I think about I think about
why am i soaked today I spoke to three
separate people two employees and a
friend who are completely incapable of
being the bigger person in every
situation I pushed so hard for them to
be the bigger person they act like the
bigger person the person doesn't
reciprocate and they completely crumble
they're mad that they were the bigger
person they feel it's incredible to
watch people feel crippled by the
thought that somebody's getting over on
them it is devastating for me to see
that people struggle with the idea that
kindness is the strength not the
weakness so many of you are being told
to be less kind and less of a pushover
and charge more and stand up for
yourself and it's ludicrous talk
kindness is the ultimate strength in our
society
that's true and when you deploy it and
you give more to your customer to your
audience when you're actually putting
out content that isn't a trick to get
into a funnel your free 7-day trial
that's a complete piece of [ __ ] to
really get site ready to sign up and pay
is dog [ __ ] dog [ __ ] [ __ ]
when the intent of what you do is
selfish you will lose and here is why I
don't know if you've heard but now
there's a thing called the internet and
in the internet everybody can play which
means unlike many years ago somebody who
has better intent who likes what they're
doing more than you which means they're
gonna work harder at it is gonna come
across and take your stuff and what
you're gonna be left with is the bottom
feeding people the most desperate and if
you want to put your head on the pillow
by attacking and bottom feeding at the
lowest of the low and our society knock
yourself out
you live you it's just not interesting
to me and so I am really interested in
the time we live in first of all a
couple random thoughts about content
I believe that producing content on an
everyday basis at scale is the answer to
98% of the questions in this room about
their businesses the nonprofit the like
you want to get somebody elected all of
the above it is the answer the ability
to post produce for Facebook Twitter
Instagram snapchat your podcast your
vlog your text messaging platform that
you're gonna have tick-tock the ability
to understand how a picture or a video
or written sentence works different on
every one of those nine platforms is the
unlock it is why I have super strength
right now in the marketplace that is my
deep religion I do not use a platform to
post a photo to all the platforms
because I understand that they have to
be unique within the environment they're
delivered I can't make an All Blacks
reference in New York they don't know
what the [ __ ] rugby
is in the same way of me making a subtle
baseball-reference here is not gonna
play context matters and so many people
just want to check the box of putting
out content they don't understand that
the reason I'm winning across every
platform is because of the context not
the content that I understand that you
you the same person when you go on
LinkedIn is different than that person
an hour later on Instagram because your
mind sets different sliding into the DMS
is different than getting a job you
understand I believe that that ability
and your ability to be self-aware of
what kind of communicator are you are
you comfortable in front of a camera
many or not can you write I cannot which
is why 2002 to 2006 was the biggest
blank part of my career cuz that was the
era of blogging and I couldn't afford to
pay writers and I can't write for [ __ ]
to this day my poor English teachers
cannot believe I have five New York
Times bestselling books and so that's
self-awareness and ability to produce
content that's post produced to the
places where people are paying attention
is what's been going on for a hundred
years right
the best writers when newspapers
dominated were important voices the
person that had gift for gab on the
radio in the 30s and 40s and could hold
an audience she or he won
Muhammad Ali understood television
that's why you know him and so the
individuals that understand how to story
tell where other humans are at that
moment in history have consistently
outperformed the rest where I get
frustrated and where I implore you to
understand is unlike the last hundreds
and hundreds of years where somebody was
the gatekeeper of who was allowed to
talk to the world the person that owned
the network the producer right today we
don't have that in the same way that the
best rap
in the world can now just upload to
SoundCloud and Spotify and win because a
record label doesn't have to sign her
you can do the same on these platforms
this is free these platforms cost
nothing to distribute on there's some
level of cost and making but at first
like I did for the first nine years I
produced myself my words my videos and
so I am frustrated / excited to push
this evening to get you to produce and
there's only two things it's either in
your head because you're insecure or you
talk a big game and you're lazy as [ __ ]
you have to make enough debating enough
overthinking I have so many answers not
cuz I was smart it's because I made
millions of pieces of content and
watched what worked I have a thought I
make it does well great
it does terrible even better that is my
framework that is what will work for
every single person from that corner to
that corner
it's what's working for every brand and
business period in and the story and
that's it that's what I'm trying to get
you to do so as I as I said waited to QA
here's why I did that and what we can do
in QA why did that as macro micro is my
world this is why are you not doing it
and then I'll tell you how to do it
right that's it why and how if the
people are about blowing up right now
want to ask me about managing people I
have a thousand employees I've done it
my whole life happy to answer if you
want to talk about where to invest your
money I've done a good job with it happy
to answer it if you want to ask anything
about anything influence your marketing
you know Amazon arbitrage you know
blockchain augmented reality message
BOTS I'm here
I'm happy to answer it but they are all
secondary to what I spent my first 10 15
20 minutes on if you are not making
content for the internet you're making a
humongous mistake
if you are not thanks mom
if you are not and thank you and let me
tell you why cuz you're gonna regret it
let me promise you one thing that I
enjoy and my goodness I do have my own
little weird things I love taking this
video running it in four years on
whatever the Instagram is of the day to
people in New Zealand and I'm gonna look
at you right in the camera cuz you're
gonna see it because I'm gonna know what
I'm doing I'm gonna say you [ __ ] up I
came in 2019 and I told you what to do
and now LinkedIn and tick-tock are too
big it's too loud it's not working the
same way and why didn't you do it I do
that every day I live it every day now
so I'm gonna live it again so please
either debate with yourself or line up
and ask a question now that unlocks why
you're not making because making not
meetings making not reading making not
coming to a Gary Vee [ __ ] conference
making is gonna unlock your [ __ ] not
watching my content and thinking you're
doing something actually doing something
yeah thank you
line up let's go
let's do it so how many mics do we have
this one those just a two in the middle
great I have no idea why this is not
being filled up but I highly recommend
you fill it up oh you've got them over
there
understood okay I'm ready to go let's go
hi Jenny thanks so much for being here
today my question is about how do you
act from your true self and from a place
of love and wanting to connect with
people but then take no [ __ ] when
they give you [ __ ] well first of all
a lot of people aren't actually giving
they're manipulating so first I have to
understand if you're manipulating or if
you're actually giving let me explain
because giving is actually giving
without expectation so when you give the
person's reactions have no weight what
most people are doing is they're fake
given they're doing something with an
expectation of something in return so to
answer your question first you need to
audit are you actually giving or are you
setting up something that you're looking
for and if you're actually giving when
they give you too much [ __ ] if
you're purely giving and you're being
taken advantage of
stop giving to that person there's seven
other billion people to give - yeah I
mean it it's really important to me like
you know I see a lot of my own employees
friends startups um an investor in
contemporaries acquaintances former
employees they think they're giving
they're not giving you understand yep
thank you you're welcome
hi hi Gary my name is Patricia and we
actually came to this event last week in
Sydney so thank you so much for allowing
us to get up and ask questions thank you
our we're based in Queenstown and we
have an accommodation business okay it's
grown very organically and we've taken
twelve months to sort of figure out
whether or not we want
go large with it okay we've got some
good numbers now around what our
demographics look like okay and we need
to really kick off a good marketing
strategy but a big chunk of our
demographic Asian markets Asia so what
would your recommendation be in China
Regina specifically shall we chat yep
Weibo but marketing online talking about
you know videos and one on Instagram
what's the best strategy for that when
it's a foreign language transcribing it
so just literally instead of having a
video it just I know you know it's
really interesting like I know we're
getting giggles but like what's super
crazy is so much of this is very
common-sense and simple it's that
something happened where I just don't
fear the thought of wasting time or
money and everybody else does people are
either insecure and will end or have a
fear of wasting time or money which
makes sense to me I understand it it's
just the answers in Reverse you need to
go to KO else right key opinion leaders
influencers in China pay them to give
awareness to your business you need to
make content and transcribe it into
Mandarin and run out we chop and Weibo
thank you very much you're welcome
hi-hi busily huge fan and I was in
Brisbane last Thursday checking in to
follow me and I watched at least grace
you might remember her she spoke to you
and I went home I was like damn I wasn't
my that girl so I booked flights on
Sunday and flew over here yesterday just
to see you and ask you two questions
amazing thank you
I feel like the Grateful Dead everyone's
touring with me seriously I you know
like I coach people and I you know step
up but I wasn't stepping up enough and
I've been going to start this podcast
for either so I actually started my
podcast went live last night good for
you yeah and it's called three wines and
everybody goes with my book what does
that say but my next question I'm sure
you know what its gonna be
can I interview you on my podcast
no but I'll make you promise yeah you
get to a hundred episodes and I'll do
episode 101 yes you can come on what's
up brother hi I'm Rob hyah hyah hyah and
my question is I'm a bit unclear on what
is business in entrepreneurship
I'm a bit confused with what is it about
like is there any rules to play on well
yeah don't be a dick got it but it's you
know entrepreneurship and business is
predicated on providing a service or a
product in exchange for money
so there's don't be a dick the only rule
to me there's one other very important
rule make more money than you lose
because then you get to keep playing but
I mean where are you going with the
question to help me here
because it's such a lofty floaty basic
question so there must be something
behind that well because everyone is
fluttering around with all these
industries and when I listen to other
people with the expertise it's different
things but we're not listening to you
it's the same thing I see a story on
Instagram the same thing as when I
listen to you as a it for mercial on a
milk bottle in the 1800s
okay the same thing so I want to get
well with Arnold Schwarzenegger when it
comes to bodybuilding he's big on
building that foundation yeah so I don't
want to be your flashy I want to have
this really still smooth great so I
think now I understand so the number one
thing that you need to do is just do
that well you know what people my
biggest fear is that people try to be
like me and the only thing I want them
to be like me is actually being
themselves
right like for example I'll be very
frank with you I struggle at some level
with the fact that my personality is so
loud and hyper
and high-energy because what I believe
in you know I always say to people I'm a
tortoise in a hares costume I'm very
slow I'm very patient I'm meticulous I
like you know yet
my energy is frantic and thus people
think it's fast but but that's me and
I'm fine with that too and so I don't
try to forcefully tone down you just
need to be yourself well but another
thing another thing that I'm very proud
of that I think will work for you I have
never sold anything in my life not
baseball cards not wine not vaynermedia
that I didn't want a hundred thousand
percent believe in and I believed the
majority of this room sell something
they don't believe in they just want the
money yeah I want to be to for my people
of Mario throughout Polynesia to be
bitter because I was thinking of all
these suppression things or as a child
and I think now in my mind I had this
thought and now this oppression thing
everyone talks about now a mental cage
yep it so I want to as humans to expand
instead of have a cap I understand it is
what I'd like to do it
hey Gary hi everybody so we question for
your sue I'm a very passionate dad good
and I feel like Dad deprived kids are
really more susceptible to you know
feeling academically socially they're
more like a dude on crime and commit
suicide okay so I'm an educator here in
New Zealand
yep being the edge getting for 15 years
and I've known ten kids that have taken
her life at my own school yes so my
question to you is what's the most
important thing a dad can do to help his
kids live a life of purpose and meaning
listen the biggest mistake that dads and
moms make is they don't listen they try
to impose the number one thing a dad can
do is pay attention to who their child
is not impose who they wait who they
wish they were dude I have no interest
in my children being entrepreneurs I
have no interest in them being like me
I've interest in them being who they are
and supporting the living [ __ ] out of
that while making sure I instill
kindness and empathy and gratitude and
thematics that I know are very important
but for all the passion I have of
entrepreneurship the only thing I'm
actually passionate about is
self-awareness and for people to do what
they should be doing and parents are
parenting their children predicated on
other parents opinion or the judgment of
other parents not based on who their
kids actually are parents would rather
have a bumper sticker on the back of
their car of a fancy school and an
unhappy child than a happy child it's
[ __ ] up absolutely thanks brother you
got it
hey Gary how are you good good glad you
finally got to come back to your
favorite country two questions how do
you constantly love the process because
the process isn't always fun so what are
some ways it's fun for me I guess a lot
of some advice find one for you okay is
it easy-peasy
it's it's it's that easy you know for
there there are people in the world who
genuinely love what they do whether
that's being a stay-at-home dad whether
that's being a painter a chef right now
the danger of entrepreneurship is it's
so predicated [ __ ] money that people
are doing [ __ ] that they don't like you
understand my days off I go garage
saling and buying [ __ ] for a dollar and
selling it for two right like I'm on
flights from America to Australia for
this trip and I'm staying up for nine
hours looking on ebay trying to buy
Messi and Ronaldo rookie cards business
buying and selling is my hobby I don't
want a [ __ ] golf yeah so so it's
about finding a process you actually
enjoy that may not map to the thing that
makes you the most money mmm I promise
you at ninety nine years old living 90
plus years of happiness versus wealth
creation always works out right another
quick question you've probably been
asked this a million times can I run up
onstage grab a quick selfie with you
facing back is that all good
no no but you can come up here and I'll
take a selfie with you because I just
want to be fishing sounds good let's do
it good go ahead me either Gary how's it
going good
the question for you is what's the
biggest way to motivate clients or
businesses that don't want to change by
speaking your truth and then actually
not trying to convince them by moving on
to ones that are further along I have
spent no time through the years with
vaynermedia which was selling something
nobody understood in 2009 I spend no
time convincing people that's the
biggest mistake that businesses that do
b2b business make on sales they
[ __ ] years trying to convince the
unconvincing oh is it this is a very
important breakthrough for you if you
listen to me there are literally
meetings I have sometimes that are
scheduled for an hour that's a new
business pitch that I wrap up in 15
minutes cordially and leave because I
can sense it's over before it started
it's the one it's a very very important
answer to that question hi I'm super
well thank you one now so maybe the
oldest in the room um I've been
following it your advice totally and
during the content and building the
business and I'm very patient
so where to from here so where are you
at I'm doing really well I'm doing the
content and I'm really getting on with
the social media I'm doing everything
that you've asked me to I just want to
know what's your advice for the next a
few more fact you know how honestly play
with me here how many pieces of content
are you putting out a day don't [ __ ]
me
and I'm not bullshitting you kind of try
I'm running multiple I believe how my
biggest probably 15 pieces a day
great he already okay I'll tell you a
place where a lot of you can get a lot
of pay dirt Twitter I'm I'm really
fascinated by Twitter and I looked at
the metrics of what's going on in this
country or Twitter doesn't have to be
the biggest platform for you to get the
most value you can post a lot of you
have ideas thoughts hypothesis
you know curiosity's posting content on
Twitter in written form with a default
gift that twitter has where you don't
even have to make design is an
incredible way to say something and see
if there's something there that would be
a way to get from 15 to 30 in a much
easier way that's strategic that helps
you get insights not just make content
pick things there and big shout out to
Dirac and what I'm here can I get my
content creators on to get a federal
favour with you you can thank you
where is he there he is go ahead me I'm
ready for you bro hey Gary
my name is Imani although if I do
comparative gaming events for the
community love it I think I meet you in
the arena grounds I don't know
wait guys oh yeah okay anyways I've got
a few questions for you
I was just wondering no sorry I just
wanted to congratulate you on the
Minnesota spot and the call of duty will
be here yeah man miss Wilson also out to
see if you could touch base on your
decision-making around committing to the
competitive gaming scene I think eSports
is gonna be one of the three biggest
sports in the world in 20 years
marvelous I was wondering if he could
also uh yeah I was wondering if you
could also give a few words to to this
to the parents and the young youth to
try and validate their their choice to
compete yeah I mean look you know I'm
part of the generation where parents
much like they're doing the iPads and
social media and phones now demonized
the [ __ ] out of video games and every
kid that was on it was wasting their
time and meanwhile if those kids stayed
the course they would be making tens
hundreds or millions of dollars at
events today and the legends in eSports
I think parents are very bad at a lot of
things and I think one of the things
they really struggle with is
anticipating where the world's gonna be
when their child is actually a grown up
they parent based on the past instead of
the future and to suppress it now when
you have Booga winning three million
dollars at a fortnight tournament how is
a parent walking around earth right now
not realizing at least giving their
child a chance to show that they're
great at video games is is no different
than them showing that they're great at
rugby or proper soccer or golf like we
like I don't understand the only thing I
understand is that parents mother or
father or brother or sister or other
parents are [ __ ] on them for the
amount of time they let their kid play
video games and it is something that I
want to put pressure on because it is a
fundamental mistake not
every kid is gonna become a [ __ ]
gaming superstar but showing your
children that you support their
interests is a very important forever
win thank you for that could I just ask
two more things sorry you're getting a
little greedy big guy yeah sorry yeah go
fast
oh no did I could I mean to my gaming
event that's coming on the video for
focus I'm sorry could I mention my
gaming event that's coming on the 30th
of August you want to pitch in this room
right now yeah you think that's a good
idea I don't know I'm asking you a
question the answer is yes or no I mean
there's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
that means the season so go ahead hey
guys so on the 30th of August we're
going to be doing a event code gave us a
game Haven it's mainly to focus around
connecting the community and also what's
a cord kind of encourage community good
community culture healthy lots of cord
interactions online and whatnot so if
you guys want to drop by on the video
for focus at the tier 2 Peninsula
community center that'd be awesome
thanks
yo what's up Gary how are you I'm good
quite brief I want to document not
create create yeah yeah that's the one
the thing is I've got so many things I
want to talk about man how wide or
narrow do I go with my focus is
seemingly possible
yeah and why would that be because it's
better okay because the reality is you
have no idea what anybody wants to hear
from you yet yeah so what are you gonna
arbitrarily pick there's literally no
downside yeah
that's why and you would you give an
amount of time the force you know if
something's working them up yes how long
years
so handful things at once okay maybe
wider the number one advantage you have
is the potpourri of your different
interests you know the fact that I
garage sales sports cards wine business
that's what makes me different and some
people don't want that content and I'm
sure when somebody goes through my
Instagram and sees to this is a post
around garage saling and they're there
for social media tactics they just skip
through it I'm not charging them it only
cost him a hundredth of a [ __ ] second
do you understand good thanks man you
got it hey Gary how you doing man super
well brother so I got a simple question
colonel um I've been doing business with
my dad for the last two years okay but
because of a couple of shady deals and
some false promises we've unfortunately
had to liquidate one of our businesses
recently okay so this has caused me to
[ __ ] hate business okay because of
all the Sharks and the shady things that
happen in the business world well me
maybe you should hate the judgment calls
that you and your dad made not business
yeah so so my second question for you is
how do you develop the mindset it's a
kind of by becoming accountable for the
fuck-ups you guys made you understand so
just to give a bit of context the [ __ ]
up that we made I know the [ __ ] up with
that we made is that a gentleman came to
us from a big company said yeah we're
gonna give a contract wouldn't give your
contract were in a given contract we saw
the contract but it never got delivered
happens yeah you shouldn't have listened
you made a bad decision to believe
people need to be accountable you know
like I've had a really hard time getting
ripped off that's a skill set but it's
okay because here's what's amazing
you're young as [ __ ] so now my intuition
says you may not make that same kind of
mistake the next time or not put
yourself in I make mistakes all the time
they just won't put me out of business
every time somebody comes to me lately a
lot of you I for some reason went on
this run of like ten kids in like a
month coming up to me at airport saying
they got ripped off and without knowing
a thing different than your scenario I
looked at them it's and I said cuz you
wanted too much money fast you know
people get ripped off when they try to
make something happen too fast
a lot of times that might not be the
scenario here but I think you're smart
enough to realize four sharks
nine sharks sounds like one big shark is
not an indication to everybody else you
know I just think everything is my fault
even when somebody steals for me it
makes me real happy I mean it I
understand how that's you know it's my
truth
it's how I think I didn't need to employ
that person I didn't need to let them
into my office I think when you go fully
in on accountability the world gets
really happy when you think it's
everybody else's fault and you don't
have control that's where people get
upset thank you you're welcome
clean up with Amana watt CT at the mono
opioid-related theory ocarina arterial
Aloha tatata Fonua anuradha know my
hooky my codeine a phenotype say Carrie
Carrie
my name is Ronnie Raymond my brother
with one sit on the hakufu I remember
very very very well very well
Monday these two things they come which
it's about content in storytelling yeah
I just want to tell a quick story about
what I said to you in Maori the minority
tea is a bird that flies against the
wind the Manoa Pajaro as a first aid
some update swims up the current and
it's one of the highest acknowledgments
that I was taught from a mental of my
name I've never actually said that to
someone say it's one of the highest
acknowledgments and Teairra Mari and I
just needed to say that to you brother
say guess I might hide in my brain but
my
so my question we Gary of being
listening to you religiously for a
little while and pumping our content has
definitely added a lot of value to my
journey and the more that I'm sharing
the more attention I am getting but I
think for myself and like three years
ago I wouldn't be in this position
because of lifestyle choices but I think
my question for you is how do you deal
with because I'm about to achieve the
biggest thing that I've set out to
achieve and I'm just getting a little
bit overwhelmed how do you deal with the
big sense of scaling with gratitude
tattooed on my fingers dog then it
sounds like this should be easy as [ __ ]
for you bro you know look look I think I
think that taking a step back and
understanding when you achieve something
that you've set out to that's big can be
overwhelming and I understand that but
when you take it with humility and
gratitude and you recognize that you put
in the work and you did the right
behaviors to get there and now what I
would do is not smell those roses don't
get high on your own supply and set
bigger [ __ ] goals
I love you Gary man this is so crazy
you have my life's respect thank you to
know that I know you talked a lot about
college debt yes here in New Zealand our
first year of university is free I heard
with that would you encourage more young
people to try uni or are their pursuit
of business or in creative fields more
important to delve into as soon as
possible it comes down to self-awareness
for a ton of kids that first year in uni
is exactly right and for other kids it's
right for them to go and do their
creative journey go travel to America
start a side hustle the biggest thing
I'm worried about when I talk about my
real disdain for the American school
system is that that means you have to be
you know you know the alternative is you
have to be an entrepreneur it's just not
true
I think a lot of people should go work
and not collect debt and have a head
start because American College is with
all the debt they have don't mean jobs
any more like they did in the 70s when
you have something for free just cuz
it's free doesn't mean it's good yeah
you know and so it seems right but it
could be a complete waste of a year and
when you go into a system that you
shouldn't be a part of and you see
people that are part of a system and it
is right for them it actually often
leads to a lot of insecurity you know
people start asking why is everybody
else here at uni having a great time and
I hate it which gets them into a dark
path so I think it's a self-awareness
game and I think the most important
thing and as I look at young people I
always try to remind them by the way not
only young people old people me 40s 50
80 90 like we struggle with
contextualizing time life is [ __ ]
long like as much passion as I have for
20 year olds I have way more passion for
50 and 60 year olds because they're
thinking about wrapping it up and
they're not even halfway home the [ __ ]
who hears between fifty and sixty like
you know we grew up in generations where
that was like you know up there like but
meanwhile you [ __ ] gonna live for
another 30 40 50 years
the [ __ ] are we wrapping up or at
[ __ ] halftime I mean that and we need
to think that way everybody's winding it
down playing defense wrapping it up
let's go on triple offense you're Bix
you're in the prime now you know what
not to do and you've got half your
[ __ ] life in front of you so you're
one year of going entrepreneur or going
loony or you know is not gonna mean [ __ ]
it's the answer is right - all of it
yeah I love you Gary can I take a selfie
you can hi Gary hi hi
I was wondering if you could offer an
opinion about SEO and search engine
optimization is it did is it raining any
money on it
it's not dead but it's mature which
means it's not a deal got it that's all
it's not super complicated you know if
you have a great landing page that
converts if your website converts like I
I would do SEO and SEM if it if I liked
the numbers I just know that Instagram
Facebook and LinkedIn do better when
you're good at it that that's where
people get confused there's a lot of
people here who think Facebook ads suck
but it's because they're bad at it got
it so it's still okay it's just that I
want to make sure that you triple check
cross your T's and eyes on the other
stuff especially LinkedIn a sister
listen to me
[ __ ] LinkedIn and I laughed like
sometimes of these talks and I leave and
I see on Twitter like I wonder if Gary
B's being paid by LinkedIn like I've
spent 20 years establishing I have one
interest to be historically correct I
don't give a [ __ ] if LinkedIn dies
tomorrow I care about today this second
I can't wait to make fun of social media
in ten years I built my wine business on
SEO got it
hi hi so we're starting an eco friendly
brand at the moment great to launch and
so we have limited money obviously a lot
yes and what would you recommend the
first platform or do we just across all
platforms a little bit or selling
something
yeah active eco friendly active we're
tik-tok and LinkedIn ok and Instagram
those 3 um Instagram is mature now with
influencer marketing content for brands
so if if you were to do it 5 years ago
when I was screaming about that
arbitrage it would have been better but
now with limited dollars here's why I'm
pushing LinkedIn LinkedIn is a platform
right this second that you could have
never posted on for your activewear for
your law firm for whatever you do and
your first post gets organic reach that
you don't deserve got it
that's why it's so powerful tick tock I
think is super interesting but the
content you make will probably have to
be to get a 12 year old girl to let her
mom know about your brand do you
understand so you have to be thoughtful
but my intuition is it's got a prayer to
actually become Instagram and that's why
it's worth investing because if you make
it through 24 months and you're there on
the other side and it does and you start
at first you can crush tick tock the
same way that people crushed Instagram
in 2013 got it hi hi Gary how are you
good to see you thank you I'm happy to
see you too my name is Thea and my
question is what would you recommend for
the young people who are figuring out
their thing in life who are also
overwhelmed by the number of things they
try and the number of information and
courses they can chew they need to play
out the game of judgment this is a game
of judgment it's not overwhelming if you
didn't worry what anybody thought bless
you can I take a photo you videos only
if you sit with me on this question for
a second okay sorry no it's okay
excited that like you know there is no
right answer people struggle with
decisions without realizing they would
never know what the other outcome would
be I make decisions every day in one
second because I know that I won't know
the other thing let me give an example I
famously passed on uber twice in the
angel round from one of my best friends
the worst financial decision I've ever
made
I missed if I wrote my normal cheque and
I was writing plenty of checks then I
would have I would have five to eight
hundred million dollars in my bank right
now right uh it doesn't even cross my
mind there's a loss because where I go
in my mind because this is how real life
works is if I did write that check over
the last five or six years my brand
would be even bigger more known for such
a great phenomenon I would have been on
different places invited to different
places and in one of those times I might
have had to go to China to give a speech
and while I was crossing the road get
hit by a bus and I know I mean this I'm
fascinated by people's inability to not
understand this [ __ ] is not binary right
you might have picked the wrong person
to marry but the other person might have
gotten cancer and that and that
devastation might have put you in life's
depression like there's so many
variables I understand why people think
like it's one way or the other it's just
life is gray the [ __ ] is not black and
white
it's easy to make a decision with all
these choices and information pick one
okay thank you you can have a selfie now
okay what's up brother mi just wanted to
say a huge thank you for coming I listen
to you every morning so huge information
we [ __ ] it
trulicity got one big question yes I
know you're a big advocate for eating
[ __ ] for a couple of years so you can
have caviar for the rest of your yes but
you're also huge advocate for happiness
of a money huge so my question for you
is as a 20 year old I'm pretty young got
my whole life in front of me yeah would
you recommend picking progression or
happiness happiness happiness is
progression
okay got it that's the confusion brother
the question was confused happiness is
the [ __ ] progression what progression
title extra zero in your bank account
buying dumb [ __ ] happiness is the
[ __ ] progression okay thank you
you're welcome
can I get a photo the happiest person in
this room the one that wakes up with the
least pressure in their chest is winning
is winning euros losing the one who's so
insecure that they're desperate to cheat
to make money to buy [ __ ] to impress
people they don't even like we need to
change the [ __ ] game we need to
change the conversation enough enough
[ __ ]
hey Gary how are you I'm good thank you
how you doing
super well it's clear okay so I'm
working alike for things write down okay
studying okay job to survive yep
internship which is starting next week
awesome and two business areas currently
working write down I love it and I'm
just like feel like I'm just starting up
and sometimes I've found like really
hard to manage all these things in like
24 hours make sense and would you give
us some me summarize the tips yes you
manage your day or I can more manage my
day because I believe when you have five
plates in the air if to break you still
have three you clearly like me like that
game other people just want to have one
plate and are petrified for something to
break so laugh when a plate breaks thank
you you're welcome
can I take a baby Sophie you can
I try to Gary firstly I just want to say
thank you I have depression and PTSD
school things like that and you truly
have helped me
xiaolin everything I even doing this I'm
shaking I'm sorry
flattered um my name is Portia I like
the car yes I'm the 19 year old business
student currently you helped me move out
on Sunday I moved a home for first time
and so Oh Sunday I cut my job that
wasn't making me happy Monday I left
home and no I'm here it's been a very
productive okay clearly this is real I
just would like to ask if you ever
considered to deviling an ASMR content
I'm sorry I'm which is devil and is in
that content I'm a ASMR yeah would I
what I what I dabble in it yeah you know
it's funny that you have you asked that
I've been looking at it but I don't like
talking about things I don't know so the
answer is I'm not sure but you catch me
in an interesting time where I've been
trying to like I've been thinking about
like chopping down my words into like
one tone like I've been like thinking
about it you know it's funny I have
slept with a sound machine my whole life
and dabbled in different things the way
I even listen to music I think is way
more you know that then the way normal
people listen to music so it's a
curiosity but it's not something I'm
educated about so I'm not ready to
really answer you in a thoughtful way
[Applause]
big Eddie how are you very well my
friend you okay um I've been consuming
your con content from last seven years
Wow thank you
started my own business about three
years ago okay I did work for free just
like d-roc did for you and eventually
you started paying off yep so thanks for
there real quick I want to bring that up
it is fascinating to me how much the
business world specifically the creative
field likes to demonize free work I
respect it
I understand it but when nobody's
willing to pay you for your work your
work is worth zero and free work has
been a foundation of my success my whole
life and there's a lot of supply in
today's world so good good on you I'm
glad I worked for you I'm pretty sure
you understand as a immigrant in USA am
i immigrant here as well I I saw you
talking about Facebook groups back in
the days in one of your CNN interviews
so I started my group to connect with
the community it's called United Indians
in New Zealand love it it has gone up to
24,000 people now all from New Zealand
now my question is how do I make a
living out of it like I want to make
money you know like enough with the
charity now
I think the number one you think so one
of the toughest things is when you do
something to convert an audience like
that into monetization you've now
changed the relationship right it's like
if you had a best friend for seven years
and now you decided you wanted to hook
up with that person sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't
my biggest recommendation if you're
sitting on a Facebook group that is
vibrant is to ask them you should make a
very honest video and basically say I've
been doing this I've been building this
and it is my personal ambition to now
turn this into a business what can I do
that would make all of you happy
instead of doing what everybody else
does and try to do something without you
being a part of it I have a funny
feeling your answer is in one of those
comments okay the last one is I also
started our top shipping okay you know I
saw you talking about the topic yep as
well do you think it's dead now
because no it's still there it's not
even started hi Gary
thank you for for mentoring from last
two years 2017 you stick with my no more
excuses I love it
and stick with me right now and from
date from that day I had only twenty
thousand dollars in my account and
thirty thousand dollars stepped and
right now I have forty thousand dollars
in my account and hundred thousand
dollars my business on my own
congratulations and just wanna know what
should I do in my heart I won't grow
more I mean I'm only a 25 year old I
think you should invest in sports cards
Sports god yes
sure well up I'm on tennis all right now
anyway I mean look I think I think a I'm
not kidding about the sports card thing
I think it's about to explode B I think
you need to think about what got you
there a lot of time you know great but
let's act eclis whatever got you from
the financial place you were there to
now a lot of times people look for the
next step and the next step is just
doing a lot more of what got them there
in the first place you can't how are you
good how are you doing super well good
to see you again good to see you again
we had a little rant at South by
Southwest and yes I've been thinking
about the voice distinction and kind of
thinking more a little bit like the
railroad coming into continents and
voices maybe the new railroad voice is
definitely the next highway yeah so
beyond the podcast beyond elixir give me
a watch where where do you see it going
cuz I haven't heard too much let's not
downplay Alexa give me a watch saying
Alexa give me a watch is like saying
that an app on the iPhone in 2009
there's just that the amount of Alexa
skills and Google skills and Apple
skills they will be the tollbooths of
our society in a decade let me remind
you of you know in the early days of
iPhone apps people spoke about them the
same way
we just talked about an Alexis skill
right let me just remind everybody in
this room the following things are just
iPhone apps Facebook Instagram right
remember right so the biggest companies
in the world in my opinion in 10 or 15
years have the potential to just be an
Alexis skill on top of an Alexa device
right so got it so you see that as the
plan I don't know who's gonna win the
home right there could be a Chinese
company BMW may decide to make speakers
and everybody goes there but whoever
penetrates the home with a device has an
open platform for us to build on right
whoever builds the most meaningful apps
on that platform will build very very
very uncomfortably large businesses
because it is much faster to be in your
kitchen in 2029 and say Alexa send me a
pizza than it is to find your phone open
up whatever version of seamless you guys
have here find a pizza spot hit four
buttons when you understand how addicted
you will be to voice devices in a decade
you will think back to this talk and
realize how [ __ ] smart I am
just just one more was yes my my son
finally likes listening to you in the
car God because of the rookie cards so
do you think do you think he and we can
do it properly from New Zealand you
don't enough yeah and I don't know what
the secondary market here is you know I
don't know what the eBay's or the
Facebook marketplace I don't know where
you flipped digitally here I'm not
educated but I do think you can I do and
I think there'll be niche markets and I
think there's a lot of ways to go with
cards that's really interesting to me
that cardboard pictures on Pokemon or
Magic the Gathering or soccer or
football or have you has a real upside
and makes sense when the whole world
goes digital there's human intuition to
pull the other way and I think that's
got a lot to do with it cool thanks you
got it hey what's up Gary my question
for you today would be how do I make raw
content look more appealing to people
and when I talk about raw content I mean
I am passionate about talking about
mental health and depression and only
because I've overcome that stuff in my
life but I feel it's more my funny dance
videos that draws a lot of Attraction
but it's more I just want to encourage
more like the younger people into people
who are going through those same life
experiences don't over worry about the
likes okay can I make it more appealing
or so I don't worry about making it more
appealing you can I don't know if you
have to worry about it you may want that
creative challenge but the way you do
that is by trying a bunch of different
things the problem is people are so
caught up in short term metrics they
intuitively know what works and they
keep doing more of that instead of doing
what they want to do you'll keep making
those dance videos the pretty guy or
girl will keep putting out shirtless
posts or booty shots instead of talking
about what they want because they're so
addicted to the short term metric yeah
just keep putting out whatever rules
just keep putting it out keep putting an
and raw content or what you're talking
about is really the creativity's in the
words and how you put them together your
what your one three sentence video away
from changing the equation
you just have to keep doing it and deal
with the ramifications of it not doing
as well as your videos where you dance
that's cool
I know it's been times up but I'm gonna
keep going since they're not coming I
also want to take a question or two from
up there I feel like you guys have been
left out so I got to figure out how to
do that oh you got a mic up there or are
you just raising your hand go talk I'll
repeat it how do you choose what
platforms good for your business so what
let's just be very direct what you can
see you know you can if you've got some
[ __ ] acrobatic [ __ ] or you know or
you want to just deal from there what
what is your business what's that long
maintenance so for me I think Facebook
and instant Instagram and LinkedIn will
probably work for you you know like and
by the way again this is some of the
themes today and try Twitter and maybe
you make a funny video of you mowing
lawn on the background of music and all
of a sudden goes viral on tik-tok and
all the dads of the kids that see it
become aware of your business
like like to me this is just one big
game of make I can give you advice I
could try to limit it here's my bigger
thing if you have a business that you
want to be successful my bigger question
is auditing your time on what you're
doing when you're not working or what
you're with your family so that you can
have more time to make across more
platforms you know you know they cook
like all I have limited time I'm like
okay I understand there's family and all
that but if your ambition is to build a
really nice-sized business to be
successful financially I think we need
to start auditing Netflix and fortnight
and garyvee videos
Cheers hi Gary Vee I'm a lover of your
content and so's my sister I have a
question please I have a business right
now I'm self-running I run I run a cab
just tell me it has to do with your hair
Florida this it's [ __ ] amazing thank
you
I run a caricature business and right
now it's going a bit too well if you
know what I mean like I don't but tell
me it it terrifies me because I have no
competition currently and I have I'm
just worried about the clientele running
out or competition coming in or a coming
storm of any kind let me give you one
storm that you can't pay attention to
competition yeah then one of the great
themes in this room brother that is
hurting people is they spend more time
worrying about their competition than
they do about their employees or their
customers when I tell you I know nothing
about my competition I know nothing not
a [ __ ] clue it doesn't matter what
what a lot of people struggle with is
knowing how much abundance there
actually is they fear that them losing
something that somebody else is actually
taking from them they don't realize how
much there actually is we struggle with
quantifying abundance we struggle with
quantifying time and so please don't
worry about competition somebody copying
you is a good thing not a bad thing yeah
what about the other storm sort of
storms like how do i cement my roots in
the community basically or by leaning in
and providing them value yeah you know
by understanding what they're looking
for from you and delivering on that okay
you know the reason I have a real
community is because I'm delivering I'm
bringing more value I'm giving you guys
way more than I'm asking for in return
like way more you know and most people
are fake giving because they want your
money I don't want your [ __ ] money
I want your admiration can I take a
selfie yeah let's do it
hey guy don't stop my voice to be with
me hey I'm so at the moment I'm working
full-time and I'm also working a side
hustle a couple of at the moment but the
one that's caught my most interest is
freelancing film content for businesses
like in my ultimate goal is to
eventually run my own digital marketing
a company or agency okay the question to
you is with a limited budget is it
tangible to scale this business to the
number one spot in New Zealand by
outsourcing a hundred percent of the
content that I don't create for my
clients
maybe but unlikely you don't mess with
it is you don't have enough control and
number one means what like stature
dollars to be honest I don't even know
what that is that's fair so I think look
I think when you outsource it's not
yours mmm it's like freelancers I
understand the rationale for it upfront
but I think the way you'll actually get
there is to convert to full-time
overtime
okay so start with that but essentially
in Husum yep thanks you got it any
questions up there okay great I'll take
it you're welcome what's your name
here so on okay
eight people on your staff keep going
three what apprentices yep I understand
so yeah I'm just doing this for
everybody else you have your a and you
have apprentices because you don't want
any of the outside work with the way
people do on the outside affecting your
way because you have a unique way and so
you do a present I do to something very
similar so go ahead okay okay okay
yep
[Music]
there's two things there's two there's
two things to do a realize that your
management style is not working for them
either that's an important observation
you know like we have to adjust your
whole you're holding them to an ideology
that may not be as practical to their
reality and casting judgment on
Millennials or these random eleven
people is not going to do you any good
but you are doing that you are doing
that but guess what look no no this is
great how many humans are we talking
about
we just have five and how many prior to
that no I don't know how hard it is
I only have a thousand of them
listen let's have two things two things
I really want to help
two things one then listen to me listen
to me your your this framework is going
to lead you down a very shitty path you
need to stop casting judgment and you
need to take a step back the number if
you were my sister and we were flying
home I'd say the first thing I want you
to do is call all 12 of them and have
dinner with them and ask them why it
didn't work out for them and then when
you get seven of them saying the same
thing fix that
okay gotta go I knew Mimi was gonna come
through thanks Mimi all right yes yes
sir hey I yeah sure I mean AI and
blockchain are both what social you're
just overlaying it so I don't I'm not
too overly worried about how they
interact with each other because their
macro technologies that will to your
point affect social I think the bigger
thing at such a young age and thinking
about those things what you're gonna
look for is timing where a lot of people
are gonna win and way more people are
gonna lose is not getting the timing
down when blockchain AI hits scale VR
for that matter hits scale so they're
gonna affect tremendously right I mean
you look at pokemons go that was a
worldwide phenomenon that changed
people's behaviors
you'd have to anticipate that that is
going to happen in a lot of IP
entertainment a lot of opportunities to
story tell in the real world through a
phone through you know you also have to
anticipate technology contact lenses
that naturally are activated by a are
are gonna do much better because it's
less friction you don't have to hold up
your phone when you walk into a store
and you have those contact lenses are
you gonna be able to see virtual
inventory there's so much coming I want
to remind everybody that 15 years ago we
didn't have smartphones like this is
just starting how many watch this how
many people here remember growing up
without the internet raise your hands I
mean so we're just starting so I think
blockchain is an incredible technology
that is gonna create peer-to-peer
dynamics like we've never seen before
so to me the big theme versus what my
guesses are cuz it's too early is making
sure that you really pay attention to
the timing and then you strike it sir
how are you so I'm a big believer in
hard work mutants
basically I like kind of live like that
okay I think the downside is that I tend
to want to do everything on my own when
I got high standard so I could like
locked myself in the room after
it's like learn JavaScript and build an
app likely to graphic design as well by
it does take a lot of time so once asked
you for a person that's like starting
out would you say it's best to like take
the time to learn everything you do it I
like it I don't think it's bad yeah you
know I think one of the big
vulnerabilities for a lot of people here
is they want to do social media content
for their business now and they heard me
an hour ago but they're gonna go back
and hire somebody who's twenty five and
they're not gonna know how to judge if
it's good instead of going home and
putting in the 30 or 40 hours to learn
and post and try they're gonna take the
shortcut and pay some young person like
their nephew to do it I'm a brother let
me tell you something to be who I've
been professionally for the last 25
years which is have the ability to be
the cashier at my wine store or the CEO
to be a community manager in vaynermedia
or the CEO the fact that not one person
can walk out the door and that creates
any anxiety for me because I'm a
practitioner of every skill set is my
biggest strengths not my weakness and
the fact that you're such a young
[ __ ] dude and have your whole life in
front of you I'm a big fan of learning
skills especially you clearly like it -
yeah enjoy it so don't listen don't let
the thesis of scaling fast Trump the
truth of having skills thank you you're
welcome
[Applause]
I'm gonna sneak 1 1 1 this is gonna last
1 apologize go ahead hi I'm a
photographer
great I'm slaying it on LinkedIn doing
really well get most of my business from
there hold on I this is important I'm
sure cuz I want to bring value here
today if you I'm sure you wouldn't think
that a photographer is the one that's
killing it on LinkedIn it is not the
natural way that we think about it right
true story I'm aware sister go ahead I'm
doing rubbish on Instagram what the [ __ ]
about 2 years now I tried to apply the
same strategy on instep epic fail
absolutely so I flipped it I tried to do
just general photos keeping it all
pretty still not working so other than
friends kids in other photographers I'm
just doing rubbish on insta and I'd like
to know if you've got any tips for that
No tip number one is to do a lot more on
LinkedIn you're the manifestation of my
thesis I came here and told everybody
that when you buy which is produce when
you story tell on platforms that have a
lot of attention but most people are not
filling the pipes yet and the ads are
not filling the pipes you get more than
you put out it is the nature it's like
buying beachfront property in an island
that isn't popular yet and then
miraculously 25 years later it is
popular the price went up that's what
you're doing right now Instagram you now
have to be best it is unbelievably
competitive everybody's there my
intuition in this scenario is to
actually triple down on strengths not
round out weaknesses like I do Clifton
strengths I moan about the strengths so
I how often are you posting a LinkedIn
every day how often one about know about
ten times a day love my direct you know
kind of advice is to push it to 20
Oh excellent thank you you're welcome no
no fast earlier you talked about that's
loud as [ __ ] um earlier you talked about
the two main reasons people don't do
what you talk I said you said 98% of
them will go home and they won't take
any action you said either it's because
they're in their heads now 97 because
that lovely photographer just inspired
three people for sure go ahead you said
it's in your head and you're insecure or
you you talk a big game but you're lazy
[ __ ] yes I don't think I'm lazy but I
have been a [ __ ] so I I wanted to do
YouTube I wanted to do make content on
the Internet
but because it's a personal brand and
it's not been like something I can hide
behind if I'm if I'm marketing a product
say I've been a [ __ ] I've been scared
of my friends family judging me correct
and I'm gonna ask how do I stop eating
[ __ ] you know it's it's funny I always
equate it to riding a bike and swimming
I think it's something that we can all
resonate with where you know you're you
know it seems way scarier than it is you
know the reality is is you grew up in a
framework where you over value people's
opinions the only way for you to change
that is to start getting as many
opinions thrown at you as possible yeah
I even now like thinking about it coming
up here like oh I'm scared to a whole
bunch of course but like as I'm doing it
it's not as bad gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah
you're just you know which i think is
easier than the judgment of your parents
and friends cuz you're right [ __ ] them
but your parents and friends is your
framework and it often has the answer I
genuinely believe the most blanket
advice in this room is to really audit
your friends and your family and start
limiting your interactions with the ones
that are broken
doesn't mean cut them off completely
tough to completely cut off your dad but
limiting so that you don't hear it I'm a
fan of it and do you think you need
specific intervention say hey [ __ ] you
or should I just yes I'm a big I'm like
just do it no both work but I'm a huge
fan of [ __ ] you here's why cuz a lot of
times by having that conversation you
had a perception that wasn't even there
it's like a pimple in high school like
everybody was so [ __ ] up with that
huge pimple but when they got the high
school and was completely scared of it
everybody else had their own [ __ ] nobody
gave a [ __ ] about your pimple and so you
know you may think like your friends
might think it's dorky or your dad might
think it's a waste of time
and then you tell them they're dealing
with their own [ __ ] bro the reason it's
so easy for me is I know everybody has
their own problems nobody gives a [ __ ]
about me once you understand that nobody
gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] gets real interesting
they got their own problems thank you
thank you thank you